MAX: You've got an
awesome new app,
and now you need to
think about securing
it and your user's data.
Whether you made an app
about time travel, kittens,
or hover bikes, you're probably
asking the same question.
Is my app secure?
CARTER: But like how every
application is unique,
securing applications
is just as unique.
In this video, you'll see
the example that we created
and how Google Cloud
helped us secure it.
MAX: Security isn't a
one-size-fits-all solution.
For example, if you're
making a banking app,
you're going to have different
concerns than someone
making a photo-sharing app.
CARTER: But we
can't show you how
to secure an app
we haven't seen,
so instead, we created
Add a Cat to That
to show you how Google Cloud
helps you secure your apps.
MAX: How do you use this
fantastic application?
Start with an awesome
photo, like the one
Jen Tong took in San Francisco.
You send it up to
the cloud, where
we do sophisticated artificial
intelligence to add cats.
Now we send that photo
back to you, improved.
And it even works
recursively because everyone
knows the internet
benefits from more cats.
And voila, your photo is better.
CARTER: So how did we make it
all happen behind the scenes?
It's actually a very
short Python program--
about 20 lines of
code-- implemented
using the Flask framework.
Once we get the
photo, we kick it
over to ImageMagick that
adds a cat to the photo,
and we take the result and
send it back to our cat lovers,
better than it was before.
MAX: Next, we had to
think about, how were we
going to run the software?
CARTER: We deploy this
inside a container,
a lightweight and
portable executable
image that contains software
in all its dependencies.
This lets us speed up
development and deployment
to production.
MAX: Since we're
using a container,
we're able to use Cloud
Run to click a button,
and that creates the image,
runs the image in production,
and points our domain at it.
So the app can serve cat
images to real humans.
CARTER: Now we're
up and running.
And the question that
always gets asked,
is Add a Cat to That secure?
Hmm.
Now that's a little
more complicated.
MAX: Even with an app as
simple as Add a Cat to That,
we've got a lot of work to
do to keep our application
from becoming one of those
security horror stories
you read about in the headlines.
CARTER: So what do you think?
Can you see any potential
vulnerabilities?
Let us know in the
comments below.
And in the next video, we'll
show you what we fixed.
I'm Carter.
This is Max.
MAX: Thanks for watching
and for adding more cats
to your photos.
[UPBEAT MUSIC]